im hässischen asla im Ortsteil oberlemp
soll ein Mobilfunkmast aufgestellt
werden eigentlich kein Problem denn rund
um das 400 Seelendorf gibt's ja
reichlich Platz aber jetzt wird der
metallturm mitten auf den örtlichen
Spiel und Bolzplatz gesetzt wie bitte
ein Funkmast direkt vor einem Fußballtor
die Menschen in oberlem wussten von
nichts wir haben im Dezember die Bagger
anrollen sehen haben uns am Anfang noch
gefreut es gibt ein neues Spielgerät für
die Kinder ja der Traum war innerhalb
von zwei Tagen gelutscht dann haben
wirfahren da kommt ein Mast also ich
find es blöd weil wir jeder jedes Kind
in erlemp hat immer darauf gespielt da
wurden auch Geburtstage gefeiert und
auch die Feuerwehrübung hat er auch
Übungen mit uns gemacht 2006 ist der
oberlemper Bolzplatz Teil des
Sommermärchens die Gemeinde bekommt ihn
vom DFB und einer Brauerei spendiert
Nachwuchskicker sollen hier groß werden
aber kurz vor Weihnachten rollen die
Bagger an Graben ein tiefes Loch und
pumpen sich Tonnen Beton hinein ein Mast
fürs Mobilfunknetz kommt hierher 40 m
hoch das Funklöcher gestopft werden
begrüßen die Menschen ausdrücklich aber
warum ausgerechnet auf dem Spielplatz
dahinter auf der Anhöhe gäbe es genug
Platz für ein Funkmast diese Stelle
hatten die Bürger als alternativen
Standort vorgeschlagen aber DAV will die
Stadt nichts wissen stattdessen kommt er
vors
Fußballtor das ganze obere Gebiet hier
oben ist kein Naturschutzgebiet also man
hätte den gut und gerne ein 200 m weiter
hier in die präie setzen können wir
haben ja genug Land hier wir sind ja
nicht in Frankfurt ich bin ganz traurig
wenn der nicht weggebaut wird die Stadt
asla schreibt uns der Standort des
Mastes sei alternativlos und weiter
heißt es die Stadt asla nimmt die Sorgen
der Menschen sehr ernst dass hier Naach
der Spiel und Bolzplatz beeinträchtigt
sein wird auch über Alternativstandorte
für Spielgeräte wird gemeinsam mit dem
Ortsbeirat gesprochen werden aber in
oberlemp wollen sie nicht über die
Verlegung des Spielplatzes sprechen
sondern über den völlig bescheuerten
Standort des
Funkmastes die Kinder sollten eigentlich
da drauf Fußball spielen und jetzt haben
sie halt nur noch guten Handy Empfang
sie stellt uns ein Funkmast mitten auf
dem Spielplatz auf dem bolzpalatz der
einfach gut besucht ist wo die Kinder
gerne hingehen wo die sich bewegen und
das ist für mich unverständlich und das
macht mich wütend in oberlemp werden die
Menschen nicht klein beigeben der
Funkmast soll woanders hin und der Spiel
und Bolzplatz so bleiben wie er ist